three moves but i mean this is quite a  hopeless cause and you can go rook c  well queen g3 is a bit of a threat so  rook see it runs into queen g yeah king  h2 just protect because a two pawn is  nothing you play loop c2 and okay you  can also go h4 h5 you just forget just  keep everything there just go h4 h5 and  it's it's over so black v ah can't even  go queen e6 because the knight is  hanging at the end  wow so queen e6 you trade pick up  tonight it's really interesting how in  this position peter you're mentioning  that all of black's pieces are tied and  white just gets one more army into the  game get all your toys into play go h4  and then it's just too much this is the  last straw that blake breaks black's  position and he goes for it he finds it  h5 queen eight seven check will be a big  threat and black  can't fight against it yeah and that's  it sorry those are these lines  wow that's a big win for prague he takes  the point home well it was a really  nicely played game